are you playing any sports now no uh
uh pickleball that's the whole new craze
now pickleball I love sports though I'm
gonna go to the batting cages tomorrow
but that's for the MLB is doing like a
show now where they ask you questions
while you hit balls oh that's a cool
idea but I'm just going because I want
to hit some balls your answers will just
be like whatever yeah and then crack
exactly another home run from yeah I
think it would be great to have a pitch
machine you know a pitching cage a
batting cage in the yard and yeah
wouldn't it just have access to that 24
7. if you're feeling frustrated or very
good because it's just to go back there
and yeah occasionally hit one yeah
every ninth time accidentally make
contact that's I would love that yeah me
too I
you know what we're going to start oh
okay what now I have to call your
publicist and say look I'm gonna hit up
uh set up a batting cage for Aubry where
does she live and
um then I have to look into what those
cost that's gonna be very expensive I
think so hey in the 90s you know people
get Ferraris as gifts that's what I
heard Megan Mullally told me
she got a Ferrari yeah
she'd do a podcast and get her get a
sports car every time all those 90s
podcasts had so much money to throw
around yeah ridiculous we should start
doing but we do give away when you leave
there is a little wicker tray out there
yeah and it's got a couple of snacks oh
okay and yeah maybe there's some Big
League Chew in there so it gets close no
there's nothing like that it looks very
granola crunchy organic yeah I don't do
this for the gifts I do it for the
therapy I could really help you I really
could and you
um Aubry thank you so much for dropping
by I know I
mean a lot to you me too and uh uh I
know this was a big deal for you look if
this is how we have to talk we'll do it
like this yeah let's get real quiet now
at the end
yes this is all we got and this is what
we got I want to do the quietest ending
of any podcast
did you
boom
I'm uh I'm just I'm crying I think I'm
in love now I definitely want to have
this I want to have dinner
you wear those shorts when you make me
that Tindy oh yeah I'll make you some
dinner
little little sauce on my
shorts while making the dinner you get
Greg Daniels out of here he's not
invited we were having such an erotic
moment and you brought up [ __ ] Greg
Daniels because I see you great get out
of my erotic fantasy with Aubry Plaza
get out
thank you Aubry thank you you're great
goodbye